One of the most important theorems
that the SAS congruence condition helps us to prove
is the Isosceles triangle theorem.
Before we move on to proving it,
we need to know what it exactly is.
Look at the triangle ABC.
These two sides are equal.
Let's move the triangle to the left to understand the theorem.
The theorem tells us that if side AC
equals side AB.
That is, if this side equals this side,
then measure of angle ABC
will also be equal to that of angle ACB.
This angle which is opposite to this side
will be equal to this angle which is opposite to side AB.
If the two sides in a triangle are equal
then the angles opposite them are also equal.
How do we prove this?
Let's move on to a new page.
We redraw triangle ABC
and jot down all the data we have.
Lengths of these two sides
are equal as it's an Isosceles triangle.
The first thing we should do before we prove something
is write down all the data that has been given to us.
We have been given
that segment AC is congruent to segment AB.
The next thing we have to note down
is that we have been asked to prove.
We have to prove that the angles opposite
the equal sides in a triangle are congruent.
That is we need to prove
that angle ABC is congruent to angle ACB.
Looking at the figure,
you would feel that we haven't been provided with any data.
Then how are we supposed to prove these two angles equal?
The best way to prove any two angles or any two sides congruent,
is by proving two triangles congruent.
So they become corresponding angles
and will hence be congruent.
But here we have just one triangle,
and we need to prove these two angles congruent.
In such cases we make two triangles.
We can do a bit of construction to help ourselves.
Let's draw the angle bisector of angle BAC.
We are talking about this angle.
So we draw the bisector like this.
Let this red dotted line be the angle bisector of angle BAC
and let it intersect BC at Point D.
Measure of angle BAD will equal that of angle CAD.
Now we have two triangles,
triangle ABD and triangle ACD.
If we somehow managed to prove,
that two sides and an included angle of triangle ABD
are equal to the corresponding two sides
and an included angle of triangle ACD
then we can say that the two triangles are congruent.
After we have jotted down the data given
and the 'to prove' section,
we go to the proof.
We have to look at triangle ABD and triangle ACD.
Have we been given any data about the two triangles?
Yes, we have been given
that segment AB is congruent to segment AC.
Based on our construction, we can also say
that angle BAD is congruent to angle CAD.
Now this is interesting!
We can see that this side is common to both the triangles.
We can say that segment AD is congruent to segment AD
since it is the common side.
Guess what, we just proved
that the two sides and the included angles of both the triangles
are equal.
Side-angle-side.
We can say that triangle ADB is congruent
to triangle ACD by the SAS axiom.
This in turn tells us that angle ABC
is congruent to angle ACB
since they are corresponding angles of
congruent triangles.
We prove these two angles congruent.
We use the side-angle-side axiom
to prove the Isosceles triangle theorem,
which says that angles opposite equal sides
are always equal.